[Music]
degenerative disease is painful
both physically emotionally and
financially
if you or a loved one has been affected
by any degenerative disease
including arthritis high blood pressure
diabetes add
osteoporosis or cancer stay tuned for a
pioneering new concept
in health and longevity hello and
welcome to the undoing of disease
what your doctor doesn't tell you i'm
your host marco watson
i'm here in the studio with trace
mineral experts dr joel wallach and dr
gerhart schrouzer glad to have you
gentlemen here
thank you margot good to see you
wonderful to be here dr before we
spotlight the prevention of cancer and
other diseases
can you tell us what are the strengths
of our current medical system as it
stands now
as it stands now we are absolutely
excellent and first-rate in emergency
medicine
in surgery anything that has to do with
first-rate technical
equipment in this regard we are number
one in the world dr wallach
for the last 30 years you've been
involved in biomedical research and
clinical medicine
tell us what you see as the major
weakness of our current medical system
in america today
well it's very expensive and it treats
the symptoms rather than going at the
root cause of the disease
it's unfortunate this is true the human
medical system
are there medical treatments or myths or
recommendations of the past that have
been abandoned which have now been found
to be harmful
oh absolutely uh margot the cholesterol
thing is probably the biggest fraud
ever perpetuated against american people
low salt diets are totally useless
and low fat diets
this has created more diseases more
physician physician-caused diseases now
than there were 40 years ago there's a
lot of myths that you've
discussed in your lectures before that
have been perpetuated are there any
other ones that were really interesting
i remember some that
chicken soup no longer is valuable but
but if you run into your doctor right
well for instance a myth that diabetes
is genetic
that's what i call a medical caca
that's certainly not true anal onset
diabetes which makes up 85 percent of
the diabetic population
is actually due to a deficiency of two
trace minerals chromium and vanadium
and yet and this has been known since
the 1950s
and it's a tragedy and almost criminal
that doctors continue to tell people
this is genetic and their only course
is to take insulin for the rest of their
life and there are other options
absolutely absolutely that people can
wean off of insulin
people can get rid of their diabetes
it's just a matter of some education
and doing some basic things that
everybody can afford just pennies a day
dr wallach you are a guest to over a
thousand radio shows and numerous tv
programs across the country
each year if you were to compare the
american medical approach to other
countries in the world
how would you rate it we wouldn't rank
very well
uh when it came to actual numbers margo
although the american medical system
when it comes to technology is
is the most envied medical system in the
world yet we don't set any longevity
records we rank 17th in longevity by the
world health organization
there's actually 16 other countries
whose pupils live longer than we do
we rank 19th in healthfulness that means
that there's 18 other countries whose
peoples
live longer than we do before they
develop cancer heart disease high blood
pressure
diabetes arthritis osteoporosis we rank
23rd when it comes to live births and
first year survivability of babies
and we rank dead last in a survey of 32
top industrialized nations when it comes
to preventing birth defects we rank 32
out of 32. so what this means what these
basic numbers mean margo is we have the
highest price health care system in the
world
but not the best well i thought it was
because of our american system the
capitalism stress is that but it's not
that
no it's an ignorance in the medical
profession dr wallach as a veterinarian
and physician
you've launched quite a stir how did you
come to believe that most diseases
result from
simple deficiencies well margot
as a veterinarian we learned that we
could prevent
and actually cure diseases in animals
reduce the amount
of health care cost by using nutritional
formulas and that's basically because we
don't have
insurance for them we don't have blue
cross blue shield major medical
hospitalization
we haven't come out with that yet well
they've tried it many many times but
it's actually
cheaper and more effective to prevent
and cure diseases with nutrition
and i tried to get medical doctors in
the medical industry and people who are
in a position of authority
in the medical system to adopt this
concept for human beings was actually on
with hugh downs and geraldo before he
got his nose broke for the first time
trying to get this concept across but
wasn't interesting to them and so i went
back to school for four years became a
physician
and i practiced in portland oregon for
12 years as a general family
practitioner i used everything i'd
learned
in veterinary nutrition by human
patients and it works just like a charm
and human
in fact it worked so well that a lot of
my patients used to kid their friends
and
and their relatives and they say look if
you're not happy with what doctors are
doing for you
go see doc wallach he'll treat you like
a dog but you get better
well excuse me for playing this skeptic
here but you said that farmers and
ranchers
supplement their animals food with
vitamins and minerals
well for me it's it's not hard to
conclude from that fact that their feed
was lacking something
absolutely and a farmer of course is in
business and if he has to spend a lot of
money on veterinary care
if he loses animals to disease can't get
him to market in time
he does lose money and so he's learned
through research at big agricultural
universities
that by supplementing animal feeds he's
going to keep his costs down
and he's be much more profitable
supplementing yes what does that mean
well that means adding vitamins minerals
and trace minerals to animal feeds
because they know
that our soils are deficient and plants
cannot manufacture minerals and so they
have to get them from the soil
knowing that the soils are deficient the
only way to make sure
each animal even the weakest ones in the
group get the optimal amounts of
nutrition the only way is to put it in
the feed
and blend it together blend it together
make pellets that way every mouthful is
perfect
so does that mean dr wallach that
there's a problem with our food
yes uh i know you don't recall this but
there was a u.s senate document
264. and u.s senate document 264 was
very remarkable because it pointed out
very clearly
that the american soils are depleted of
minerals nutritional minerals
and as a result the crops that are grown
there the grains vegetables fruits and
nuts that are grown in these depleted
soils
are minerally deficient and as a result
the animals and people who eat these
minerally deficient
crops get mineral deficiency diseases
and the only way to
prevent and cure these nutritional
diseases is by supplementing with
minerals
now this document is pretty scary margot
because it was written and published in
1936 1936 how come we didn't know about
it well at that time we began to put
vitamins and minerals and trace minerals
into animal feeds to make up the
difference
unfortunately for human beings we got
wonder drugs at the time
we got sulfa drugs in 36 we've got
penicillin and 38
we've got cortisone and 42 and everybody
was led to believe if we just
if we just give medicine enough money
for research and if we faithfully watch
dr mark as well be md every week
they will find a wonder drug for
everything well you know that's not true
today i'm concerned about my health
i eat a low-fat diet basically i
exercise i avoid sugar and caffeine
i don't smoke and i try to get in a
salad today
are you telling me that i still have a
high chance of getting a number of
diseases
absolutely margo because first of all
even in the best of times in history
and now and certainly in the future
minerals never occurred in a uniform
blanket around the crust of the earth
and as a result the ability of you to
get all 60 of the essential minerals you
need which
are two-thirds of the 90 essential
nutrients is
less than you winning a million dollars
each day for 30 days in vegas it's just
not going to happen
and so the only way that you're going to
guarantee that you're going to get
enough nutrients is to supplement
and of course we've tried this
experiment for 200 years americans as
you point out have eaten better than
anybody
we've had the highest quality of food
yet our average lifespan is only 75.5
about half
of our genetic potential for 120 to 140.
and there are people that live that old
oh absolutely there's six to ten
cultures that were written up
by the national geographic a very
reputable uh
group of people have a great journal and
they point out very clearly that the
oldest documented living human being was
168 years old when he died
168 can you imagine lots of golfing in
that
what do you feel are some of the
diseases you can avoid or prevent by
supplementing with minerals dr wallach
well ashley margot according to the cdc
the center for disease control
85 of the hospital admissions in america
are due to degenerative diseases
and these of course are due to mineral
deficiencies most of them
this represents an enormous cost savings
if we could prevent these things which
we can
we know we can we're talking about
diabetes which is due to a deficiency of
chromium and vanadium
we're talking about osteoporosis and
arthritis which are multiple mineral
deficiencies calcium magnesium manganese
sulfur selenium copper zinc and so on
plus some vitamins
and then of course you have cancer which
we know we can at least
significantly reduce the
rate of cancer by selenium
supplementation
how many minerals vitamins that type of
thing are we supposed to have
we're actually supposed to have 90
essential nutrients margo
those include 60 minerals that's 6 0
minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential amino
acids and 3 essential fatty acids
and they're called essential nutrients
for two reasons number one our bodies
cannot manufacture and we must consume
them every day either as food or as
supplementation
and number two if any one of these
essential nutrients is missing for a
couple of months or a year or so
we get on the average 10 deficiency
diseases so 10 deficiency diseases times
90 essential nutrients
it's 900 diseases that are preventable
with proper supplementation
dr schrozer the most dreaded of diseases
is cancer
one of three people will get it in their
lifetime and billions of dollars are
spent each year to treat it
can a correlation between cancer and
mineral deficiency be drawn
yes and selenium an essential element
is the key element that we will be
discussing today
because there's some really exciting new
news
available which i think is a true gift
to the american people
and this is a gift because it was
announced actually on december the 24th
of 1996.
a good point but few people probably
watched they looked for their presence
under the tree
and so we can talk about that dr
schrozer
as the current president of the world
biomedical selenium society
you actually discovered more than 20
years ago that selenium is a highly
effective
trace mineral for cancer prevention why
in your words is selenium so important
for cancer prevention today
selenium is an essential trace element
this has been known since 1957
but my work has shown that selenium is
uniquely
able to prevent or delay the development
of cancer
almost irrespective of the cause of it
and in this regard it is becoming the
most important element that we have to
protect us
against cancer besides numerous
responsibilities
in your professional career you've also
spent a lot of time as editor in chief
of a leading journal on biological trace
element research
why is cancer prevention so important
because cancer
is a major cause of death just think
that in the us alone
last year 510 000 men and women died
from cancer therefore anything that we
could possibly do
to prevent this disease is important and
should be done now
and people are really scared about it
too because i guess they don't know what
to do
that is correct and because cancer once
you have it
is so difficult and painful to treat
takes often years
and the end is very unfortunate to
everybody
and the costs are very formidable aren't
they absolutely
dr schrozer one of your major research
interests is the prevention of cancer
with selenium
what evidence is there to justify the
use of selenium for the prevention of
cancer
by now the cancer protective and
preventive effects of selenium have been
demonstrated in virtually
hundreds of different animal experiments
and we now know that selenium protects
not only
virtually against all chemical
carcinogens but also
against cancer producing viruses
and this is something especially
important because more and more it is
recognized that viruses
that often may be hidden in the body for
years eventually
may turn normal cells around and turn
them into cancer cells
and therefore it is of utmost important
to have something there that may even
prevent
oncogenesis as we call it by viruses
and selenium is that agent so even if
somebody doesn't have a genetic
predisposition towards cancer they could
get it even then
you could get it because you could have
the genetic
information of a virus in your cells
which could be activated but studies
have now
shown that you can in fact prevent this
activation
if you get enough selenium that's
exciting news
absolutely this was actually shown in
china
where there's a region north of shanghai
in which
liver cancer incidence is extremely high
and the major risk factor in this
area was hepatitis b which is a virus
and it was shown that with selenium you
could in fact prevent
not only hepatitis b but also the
occurrence of liver cancer
in the population as a world renowned
scientist and one of the pioneers in
selenium research
what is our own natural defense against
cancer
one of the chief system that we have is
our immune system
we have special white blood cells that
have the sole purpose of
killing abnormal cells that are
practically almost always formed in our
bodies
for instance when you're out in the sun
certain cells may transform of course
you don't know about this
but there are lymphocytes watching over
this
and actually are killing these abnormal
cells all the time therefore to maintain
the function
of these blood cells is absolutely
essential
and what is now so truly fascinating is
that it has been discovered that
if you give people extra semenium
you can enhance the activity of these
cells
so that they can kill five times
more cancer cells than they normally
could
and therefore our immune system is
actually
enhanced by this trace elements selenium
and so it works naturally and everything
works naturally and there are no side
effects in fact the only positive
effects
and we will talk about some of these
outside of the cancer problem
but what evidence is there that selenium
actually prevents cancer in humans
there is what we call epidemiological
evidence
which shows that for instance in areas
that are naturally rich in selenium
fewer people die of cancer
and then there are studies in which
doctors have collected blood samples of
healthy people
stored them for many years and then
looked
in that population for people who
developed cancer and then they compared
the serum blood or blood selenium levels
and they found that people who later
developed cancer
had lower selenium levels before that is
when they still were healthy they
developed cancer
and that gradually gave rise to the idea
that semantium
prevented cancer in humans and
ultimately
it led the national cancer institute and
other agencies
to fund a large-scale cancer prevention
study
which was just concluded this year and
which we will
discuss actually shortly from now
have there been some actual selenium
supplementation trials with humans to
prevent cancer
as i already mentioned to you there's
the first human studies
were actually done in china one was done
with a large
number of people in an area in which
esophagus cancer is very common
and it was found that just a supplement
containing
selenium vitamin e and beta-carotene
would significantly lower
the morbidity and mortality of that
population
the trouble with that study was that it
involved three agents
and so people as scientists as we are
are skeptical and we wondered is it this
or the other
but then there was a second study in
quidong in the area with high liver
cancer incidence where only selenium was
used
and was found to be effective and now we
have the search study done in the united
states with american patients
and there only selenium was given and
selenium was indeed
found to be effective do they call it a
water drug
well you could call it that i would call
it a wonder nutrient
because the selenium in all these
studies was given at nutritional levels
and this is actually a very important
point we must never confuse
prevention which deals with keeping
your cells normal and healthy with
therapy which involves a medical
intervention where you have to correct
something that has
already gone abnormal or cancerous so we
will talk today exclusively
about prevention the best way action
before reaction
exactly dr schrozer what makes this
study so exciting in my view
it was that the age of the participant
was older than i would have expected to
lead to a successful
study because the average age at the
beginning of the study of the
participant was 66.4 years
at that age you would think it's maybe
too late to start preventing cancer
and yet after a period of seven years of
this was the average observation period
it was found that in those
sub subjects who received the selenium
supplements the
cancer incidence and mortality was up to
50 percent
lower than in the control group which
only received placebo
that's exciting and moreover
what turned out to be for me even most
amazing that
even a terrible cancer like prostate
cancer
afflicting elderly men was very
significantly prevented by just
one agent an agent that is
inexpensive to obtain and doesn't
produce any harmful side effects
whatsoever
i think this is a study that the
american people need to know
because it really opens the door to it's
an effective
mechanism of cancer prevention much
simpler than anything
anybody would have thought in the past
and it's taken so long for us to really
grasp that information we're so grateful
you're here
have there been any unexpected results
there have been not really any truly
unexpected results but i should
caution that the original aim of that
study was
to see if patients and in fact the
participants in that study were all
former
skin cancer patients the purpose of that
study was to see
if you could protect these former skin
cancer patients
from developing metastases on new skin
cancers
and that didn't work the lesson we have
to take from this is the following
if you had cancer it is possible that
your body harbors
transformed cells now these cells are
usually more resistant and they are a
different
you can say category than normal cells
and there
a simple nutrient such as selenium is
not sufficient to
cause a true effect we need additional
measures
therapeutic measures but that doesn't
mean that selenium shouldn't be taken
you just have to watch out if you had
cancer this is a more serious matter and
you need medical attention
you need additional therapeutic
modalities to protect yourself
against recurrences so the bottom line
is really a balanced wisdom in using
med traditional methods and also
nutritional methods exactly and you have
to
very well be aware that prevention is
something else
than therapy and it's best to prevent
first too and
absolutely what are the consequences of
this for anyone who had cancer
and now wants to take selenium i think
anyone should now start can now start
taking selenium
it is only that those people who already
had cancer
still require the regular medical
checkup
and additional treatment modalities as i
have already pointed out
it is reassuring to see that one can
prevent prostate
lung and colorectal cancers
but what about breast cancer and other
cancers that afflict women
now the american study which was
directed by dr
clark from the arizona cancer center and
which involved 1312 participants
unfortunately didn't use enough women in
the study and the reason was that they
totally randomized the study they didn't
know the
the gender of the participants so
unfortunately
that study didn't produce enough good
data for
breast cancer prevention but our own
studies have shown that breast cancer
can be prevented in animals with
selenium
very well and i can even show you a
paper that was published as early as
in the united states where they treated
actually breast cancer patients with
selenium
successfully unfortunately that study
was forgotten
maybe it was world war one what one
really has to watch for breast cancer
prevention is
that one has to begin taking selenium
as early in life as possible and that is
because
the malignant transformation of the
cells
in the mammary gland can occur early
and these transformed cells often sit in
little nests
for years without doing anything but
these malignant cells then later
could actually develop into tumors
and for that reason i strongly recommend
start
with selenium as early as possible and
of course you must
maintain always
regular medical checkups
self-examination and all methods
that are available to detect memory
tumors
as early as possible because it's always
the case that some cancer cells can form
we sort of
escape the screening system of the body
so to summarize it is still necessary
to watch out very carefully in spite of
taking selenium
but please do take the menu and another
thing
one has to consider is diet i often tell
women who ask me what can i do
to protect myself so half jokingly i say
buy a japanese cookbook and
switch to a more japanese diet because
we
know that in japan the breast cancer
mortality and
incidence is remarkably low but as now
japanese are starting to eat more
western styles american food
sugars that's right the breast cancer
incidence is actually increasing even in
japan
and so i say let's turn around and say
if you are at risk of breast cancer you
think we are
at risk start live like the traditional
japanese do which is fairly easy in the
united states it's a rice style very
popular form seafood
and but you also should take selenium
with it
because we've actually done a study
where we gave mice that had a mammary
tumor virus
a simulated japanese and the simulated
american diet
and it turns out that the american diet
offered no protection
unless and until we added selenium
the japanese diet offered some
protection
but it became much better when we also
added selenium to that diet
so the answer is yes live like a
japanese lady
and take selenium that is i think a very
good recommendation we can make right
now with ethical
justification dr schrauser what is the
opinion of the national cancer institute
and some scientific peers on selenium as
a cancer preventative
a few years ago i attended a special
selenium meeting
at the national cancer institute and
there a spokesperson said
that selenium is actually the only agent
they had
that showed promise the only agent
that's what
he said now again an agency consists of
people
but i wholeheartedly agree with him
because you know there were other agents
that were touted for a while
beta-carotene for example which didn't
actually pan out
in larger studies but selenium has
actually
panned out and so yes
the national cancer institute endorses
the selenium studies
however they are cautious and in my
opinion a little bit too cautious
in making general health recommendations
at this time they want additional
studies
now i ask you would you rather wait
another 10 years
before you start taking selenium i would
suggest that you
don't wait start taking it now what's
the downside if i did take it and it
proved
that they did these 10 years of research
and nothing panicked the only
downside of you taking selenium would be
that you could be
could not be a participant of the new
study that they
would do but you would protect yourself
and
i even wonder if there is not an ethical
problem now to conduct such studies
because
i wouldn't want to participate in the
study where i would tell you
or without telling you give you a
placebo for the next 10 years
and watch until you develop breast
cancer if i already know
that the chances would be high that i
could prevent you from getting the
disease
and so these ethical problems should be
addressed and
well i believe you should take selenium
and you should take it
when we come back we'll talk about just
how old you can live to be
and we'll talk with a sweet lady who
experienced a vitamin and mineral
[Music]
miracle
inga thank you for inviting us to your
home to sit and chat hearing about your
life and
before and after your illness tell me
what did you experience when you were
sick what kind of ailments were you
facing and then what was your life
before
i faced arthritis osteoporosis
chronic fatigue epstein-barr virus
they told me i had fibromyalgia
i had my goodness thyrodectomies
his total hysterectomies
what kind of surgeries did you have i
had fusions down on my neck
where they took the bone out of my hip
uh
i had knuckle replacement done because
you had such bad arthritis
yes it completely deteriorated my
knuckles
the pain you told me was so incredible
yeah it was i took roughly seven
bicadenes a day just to be out of to do
some work some functioning you know in
my home
and you mentioned that the pain was so
bad in your leg that even the doctors
were suggesting
yes i had very bad blockages in my right
leg it
throbbed day and night and
they wanted to take the lake off because
of the pain
and i also was scheduled for more knee
surgeries
oh my goodness chronic tendonitis
carpal tunnel syndrome just like you
were falling apart
i was that's what i did so it
impacted your life obviously physically
but also financially
and mentally i went through my life
savings because of my illness for eight
years
and had them remortgage a house what was
paid for
in order to build a new house double
door
everything wide open space so i could be
moved in a wheelchair and i could
function in that house had a toilet put
in
a high toilet and open doors to get into
a shower
everything ready for a wheelchair and
you mentioned to me earlier that
it got to the point where mentally you
just didn't want to face it anymore
no the pain was just so severe
that you just there comes a time you
know you don't want to you want to end
it all
so what was the change what happened to
you that
gave you hope what gave me hope was dr
wallach listening to his radio show
the last 12 minutes of his show
he explained to a woman she had
osteoporosis of the spine
and i followed these rules
my son drove to the grocery store got
the gelatin
we ordered vitamins minerals claudium
colloidal minerals everything liquid
because you absorb it so much easier
and i start taking it day and night
i took it 10 15 times a day i didn't
think i could overdose on
vitamins and minerals because i should
have been dead with all the medication i
took
roughly 20 some pills a day my heavens
just to be pain-free so from the time
that you heard that
radio program and your son got the
medication yes how when did you start
noticing a change physically
well i kept on taking it day and night
and within three to four weeks
my back didn't go out anymore and
nine to ten weeks after all that i woke
up one morning
was pain free i felt for the first time
in 10 years
normal i felt light as a feather
and i jumped out a bit and i said my god
i can move without any help
i walk it was
like a new life yes i was like new
reborn
so what are you like now what is your
life like now i'm a hell raiser
like i used to be i swim
i hike again with my dogs i do what i
want to do again
and you credit it to dr wallick
and the minerals the vitamins the
colloidal minerals
and the gelatin and a lifestyle you
mentioned oh yes
yes i will forever be thankful to him
he changed my life i just follow what he
says
thank you inga we appreciate you sharing
your experience
and we wish you all the best in your new
life
[Music]
wasn't that an incredible story gives
all of us a sense of hope
absolutely after seeing the amazing
results mineral supplements gave inga
reagan
dr wallach should we just go out to the
grocery or health food store
and get any supplement or what should we
look for well basically margo
we have to educate ourselves on what a
mineral is there's actually three types
of minerals number one there's the
elemental
mineral this is uh relatively low in
absorption and availability to animal
and human being only
as an adult only three to five percent
to a child maybe eight to twelve percent
and in the sixties uh we actually came
up with a form of mineral known as
chelated minerals this is
because farmers aren't willing to put a
dollar in an animal's mouth and have 99
cents come out in the manure
so we learned that by adding amino acids
and proteins and maybe even enzymes
which are proteins that do work to the
elemental mineral
it increases the availability ten-fold
but the way that animals and people were
designed to consume
and absorb minerals is in the colloidal
form colloidal colloidal
yeah small particle size in suspension
and
this is 98 available to animals and
people
as much as 10 times more available than
the elemental farm
so basically what we're looking for here
for usability is either the chelated
some form of chelated mineral or the
colloidal mineral
dr schauser what is the best form of
selenium for us to take for absorption
and to avoid toxicity the best form is a
nutritional form
which is normally found in plants and
the compounds
you should look for is selenium
methionine that's
an amino acid which has selenium in
place of sulfur we call the
sulfur amino acid mesionine but plants
also produce an amino acid if you give
them enough selenium
which is selenomethane and built
that selenium into the proteins of the
plants
and therefore certain grains for
instance are rich in selenium methionine
and this selenium messianin can be found
in quality supplements
and that is the selenium that we should
be taking
at this stage for nutritional purposes
dr wallach if i don't get hit by a train
and i choose to supplement with selenium
and the other required nutrients my body
wants and needs
how old can i live to be well the fun
thing is margot
we have the genetic capability of living
healthfully now
to be 120-140 there's no reason why you
can't be playing golf and jogging and
having fun playing cards
with the girlfriends and boyfriends in
120 140.
human beings do have that genetic
capacity but i would be quick to point
out that americans don't do a good job
when it comes to longevity
we only live to be 75.5 half of our
genetic potential
and so we do need to consciously make
sure we take in all 90 essential
nutrients
so we can get there from here which all
of us really want to do
as long as we have quality of life right
people don't want to be a shrilled up
prune at 100 years old sitting on the
toilet all day so you don't have any
time to do anything fun like golf or
play and and so on so you do have to
take in all 90 essential nutrients so
that you can be healthful there
there's no reason you can't for instance
jean calment
this lady who now holds a record for
longevity and
about 122 she rode her bike for 105
years as a volunteer librarian
and certainly um everybody can do that
if we just do the right thing
in conclusion dr schrozer how can we
prevent and survive
cancer we can prevent it as we have seen
with selenium and also and this is
important
with a healthy lifestyle we should not
smoke
we should not drink excessively we
should have a healthy diet
and we should watch for small changes
which occur
and we should have regular medical
checkups to see if changes that we
cannot
observe have possibly occurred and we
should see
to it that these changes are observed as
early as possible
with this package i think we can
successfully prevent cancer
and dr wallach how can we prevent or
improve these other diseases
like arthritis diabetes heart disease or
alzheimer's
well again you've picked out diseases
that are degenerative diseases that are
either directly or indirectly related to
nutritional deficiencies and as dr
schrozer points out very
very well give up the bad things like
fried foods and sugar and caffeine
and excessive alcohol and take in
consciously supplement with all 90
essential nutrients
60 minerals 16 vitamins 12 essential
amino acids
and three essential fatty acids and of
course this includes
chromium and vanadium for the the
diabetes that includes selenium for
cancer
includes the calcium magnesium boron and
sulfur and chondroitin sulfate for
for arthritis and osteoporosis and if we
do these things we can have a quality of
life all the way up to 140.
if you or a loved one has been affected
by any degenerative disease
including arthritis high blood pressure
diabetes add
osteoporosis or cancer don't wait for
your doctor to give you permission
you've now learned many things today
that your doctor doesn't tell you
so take control of your own health and
give your body the nutrients it wants
and needs today
thank you for viewing this presentation
and remember to contact the person that
sent this to you
for more presentations and books that go
into greater detail
go to doc wallockmedia.com and be well
these statements have not been evaluated
by the fda
these products are not intended to
diagnose
treat cure or prevent any disease
the opinions expressed in this
informational program
are the express opinions of joel d
wallach bsdvmnd
are not a replacement for proper medical
advice and treatment
in all cases we recommend you contact
your physician directly
regarding any medical conditions